welcome back will now use a little bit
of what we've learned about work and
energy and the conservation of energy
and apply it in two simple machines and
we'll learn a little bit about
mechanical advantage so I've drawn a
simple lever here and then you've
probably been exposed to simple Leivers
before they're really just kind of like
a seesaw this place where the lever
pivots this is called the fulcrum just
really the pivot point and you can kind
of view this as either a seesaw a big
plank of wood on top of a triangle which
essentially is what I've drawn so in
this example I have the big blank of
wood at one end I have this 10 Newton
weight and I've written 10 in there and
what we're going to figure out is 1 how
much force well we could figure out a
couple of things how much force do I
have to apply here to just keep this to
keep this level right because this
weights going to be pushing on that one
in downward so it would naturally want
this whole lever to rotate clockwise so
what I want to figure out is how much
force do I have to apply to either keep
the lever level or to actually rotate
the sleeve or counter clockwise and when
I when I rotate the lever
counterclockwise what's happening I'm
pushing down on this left hand side and
I'm lifting this 10 Newton block so
let's do a little thought experiment and
see what happens after I rotate this
lever a little bit so let's say this
what I've drawn here and move that's our
starting position and then yellow I'm
going to draw the finishing position so
the finishing position is going to look
something like this
try my best to draw it the finishing
position is something like this oh and
also I want one thing I want to figure
out I wanted to write
is let's say that the distance that this
distance right here from where I'm
applying to the for whenever where I'm
applying the force to the fulcrum let's
say the bed distance is whoops I'm using
the wrong tool that distance is 2 and
from the fulcrum to the weight that I'm
lifting that distance is 1 let's just
say that just for the sake of argument
let's say it's 2 meters and 1 meter go
there could be 2 kilometers and 1
kilometers we'll soon see
and what I did is I press down with some
force and I rotated it through an angle
theta right so if that's theta then this
is also theta
right so my question to you and we'll
have to take out a little bit of our
trigonometry skills is how much did this
object move up
so essentially what was this distance
what's its distance in the vertical
direction how much did it go up and also
for what distance did I have to apply
the force downwards here so that's this
distance in order for this weight to
move up this distance over here so let's
figure out either one so this distance
is what well we have theta this is the
opposite this is a 90-degree angle right
because we started off at level so this
is opposite and this is what this is the
adjacent angle right so what do we have
there opposite over adjacent so
toe opposite over adjacent opposite over
adjacent
that's Toa or tangent so in this
situation we know that the tangent of
theta is equal to let's call this the
distance the object the distance that we
move the weight right so that equals
opposite over adjacent the distance that
we move the weight over one right and
then if we go on to this side we can do
the same thing tangent is opposite over
adjacent so this is let's call this the
distance of the force
so here the opposite is a distance of
the force and the adjacent is this two
meters right because this is the
hypotenuse right here so we also have
that tangent of theta now using this
triangle is equal to the opposite side
the distance of the force over two
meters so this is interesting they're
both equal to tangent of theta so they
must we don't even have to figure out
what the tangent of theta is we know
that this quantity is equal to this
quantity right and we can write it here
we could write the distance of the force
that's the distance that we have to push
down on the side of the lever downwards
over two is equal to the distance of the
weight the distance the weight traveled
upwards
is equal to the distance the weight
divided by one or we could say this this
one we could ignore write something
divided by 1 is just 1 or we could say
that the distance of the force is equal
to 2 times the distance of the weight
and this is interesting because now we
can apply what we just learned here to
figure out what the force was and how do
I do that well when I'm applying a force
here over some distance
I'm putting energy into the system I'm
doing work work is just the transfer of
energy into this machine and when I do
that that machine is actually
transferring that energy to this block
it's actually doing work on the block by
lifting it up so we know the law of
conservation of energy and resuming that
this is a frictionless system and that
nothing is being lost to heat or
whatever else so the work in has to be
equal to the work out and so what's the
work in well it's the force that I'm
applying downward times the distance of
the force so this is the work in force
times the distance of the force I'm
going to switch colors just to keep
things interesting and that has to be
the same thing as the work out right
well what's the work out well it's the
it's the force of the weight pulling
downwards right so we have to it's
essentially the lifting force of the
lever right it had to counteract the
force of the weight pulling downwards
actually sorry I miss set it a little
bit but so this lever is essentially
going to be pushing up on this weight
right the way it ends up here so it
pushes up with a force equal to the
weight of the object so that's the
weight of the object which is I said it
was a 10 Newton object right so it's
equal to 10 Newtons that's the force the
upward force here and it does that for a
distance of 1 well we figure it out this
object this weight moves up with the
distance D sub W times D sub W all right
and we know what the distance of the
force is in terms of the distance of W
so we can rewrite this as force times
substitute here to DW is equal to 10 DW
divide both sides by 2 and you have
or actually divide both sides by two DW
and you get force is equal to ten DW
over two DW which is equal to DW z--
cancel out and you're just left with
five so this is interesting and I think
you'll see where this is going and we
did a little complicated this time but
hopefully you'll realize a general theme
this was a 10 Newton weight and I only
had to press down with 5 Newtons in
order to lift it up but at the same time
I pressed down with five Newtons but I
had to push down for twice as long so my
force was half as much but my distance
that I had to push was twice as much and
here it's the opposite the distance is
twice as much I mean sorry the force is
twice as much but the distance that
traveled is half as much and what
essentially just happened here is I
multiplied my force and because I
multiplied my force I essentially lost
lost some distance but when I multiplied
my force because I inputted a five
Newton force and I got a 10 Newton force
out although the 10 Newton force
traveled for Less distance because the
work was constant and this is called
mechanical advantage if I have an input
force of five and I get an output force
of 10 the mechanical advantage is 2 so
mechanical advantage is equal to output
force over input force and that should
hopefully make a little intuitive sense
to you and another thing that maybe
you're starting to realize now is that
proportion the proportion of the
mechanical advantage was actually the
ratio of this length to this length and
we figured that out by taking the
tangent and doing these ratios but in
general it makes sense because for this
force times this distance has to be
equal to this force times this distance
and we know that the distance this goes
up is proportional to the length of this
from the fulcrum to the weight and we
know on this side the distance that
you're pushing down is proportional to
the length from where you're applying
the weight to the fulcrum and now I'll
introduce you to a concept of moments in
just a moment
so in general if I have and this is
really all you have to learn that last
thought exercise was just to kind of
show it to you if I have a fulcrum here
and if we call this distance d1 and we
call this distance d2 and if I if I have
a force if I want to apply an upward
force here let's call this f1 and I have
a downward force f2 in this machine f2
times d2 is equal to d1 times f1 and
this is really all you need to know and
this just all falls out of the work in
is equal to the work out now this
quantity isn't exactly the work in the
work in whiz this force
so our f2 is this force times this
distance but this distance is
proportional is going to be proportional
to this distance and that's what you
need to realize and this quantity right
here is actually called the moment in
the next video which I'll start because
very soon because this video is about to
end I'm laying out of time I will use
these quantities to solve a bunch of
mechanical advantage problems see you
soon